avec une téléportation je ne sais pas
comment vous avez fait mais on m'a
annoncé 30 secondes plutôt votre départ
de l'Assemblée nationale bravo en tout
cas mes chers collègues nous accueillons
aujourd'hui Marc fenau qui est ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire merci monsieur le ministre
de vous être rendu disponible
aujourd'hui pour évoquer devant notre
commission des affaires européennes du
Sénat la riche actualité européenne en
matière agricole nous avions sollicité
cette audition en novembre à un moment
délicat pour vous puisque la Commission
européenne avait
soumis aux États-membres un projet
renouvelant l'autorisation du du
clivosat pour 10 ans finalement vous
avez choisi l'abstention ce qui n'a pas
permis aux États-membres de dégager une
majorité qualifiée sur cette proposition
si bien que la Commission a
unilatéralement décidé ce renouvellement
nous souhaiterions vous
entendre sur ce choix de l'abstention
qui nous semble révélateur d'un embarras
du Gouvernement sur ce dossier pris à la
fois entre les associations de défense
de l'environnement qui vous rappelle à
votre promesse de sortir du glyphosate
et les représentants du monde agricole
qui soulignent l'absence de solution de
substitution dans ce contexte
comptez-vous maintenir les restrictions
actuellement en vigueur en France le cas
échéant quel dispositif mettrez-vous en
œuvre pour soutenir nos agriculteurs qui
risquent d'être confronté à des
distorsions de concurrence
particulièrement pénalisantes nous avons
des interrogations similaires concernant
l'usage durable des pesticides la
proposition de règlement sûr qui doit
ce sujet a été rejeté par le Parlement
européen fin novembre vous semblez
encore croire qu'il est possible de
sauver ce texte un compromis peut-il
encore être trouvé selon vous sinon
comptez-vous adapter en conséquence
l'objectif que vous aviez fixé d'une
réduction de 50 % de l'usage des
pesticides d'ici à
2030 il nous semble que nous arrivons à
un moment d'inflexion où le principe de
réalité s'impose enfin et freine le
volontarisme de la Commission européenne
en matière de transition verte qui s'est
décliné en matière agricole par de
nombreuses initiatives législatives nous
les avions dénoncé en faisant valoir
l'impératif de l'autonomie alimentaire
européenne et nous regrettons de ne pas
avoir été entendu plusut tôt je pense
notamment au texte sur la la
restauration de la nature ou sur les
émissions industrielles qui continuent
d'inquiéter légitimement nos
agriculteurs qui sont soumis à la
concurrence de pays-tiers qui échappent
eux à ces contraintes comment
entendez-vous les protéger
que peut-on attendre du dialogue
stratégique sur le futur de
l'agriculture que lance la Commission et
dans quelle mesure fera-t-il place au
défi supplémentair que l'élargissement
de l'Union représenterait pour nos
agriculteurs on a de cesse d'entendre
effectivement la question ukrainienne et
ce géant agricole qui pourrait intégrer
l'Union certes pas tout de suite mais ça
se prépare nous serions enfin
particulièrement intéressés que vous
nous rendiez compte du Conseil des
ministres de l'agricult culture de
l'Union auquel vous avez participé au
nom de notre pays cette réunion était
particulièrement attendue en ce qui
concerne la négociation sur la
législation que la Commission européenne
a proposé sur les nouvelles techniques
génomiques afin d'encourager le
développement de ces nouveaux OGM au
sein de l'Union ce pourrait bien être le
dernier grand texte agricole susceptible
de faire l'objet d'un accord avant les
élections européennes c'est un sujet
important à de nombreux égards à la fois
pour l'avenir de la recherche
agronomique européenne pour l'autonomie
stratégique et pour la transition verte
pouvez-vous nous dire s'il est réaliste
d'espérer l'adoption de ce texte avant
les élections européenne et dans quelle
mesure vous avez pu obtenir des
assurances utiles concernant la
breuetabilité
ou la traçabilité monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole puis ensuite on
ouvrira la parole à nos collègues en
prenant deux à trois questions par par
cycle je vous
remercie
que ah oui c'est mieux comme ça quand
même merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pardon c'est quelques minutes
de retard mais ils ont été limités cont
tenu d'une question qui est arrivée très
tard dans le cycle à l'Assemblée
nationale mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très heureux d'être
devant votre votre commission parce que
je pense que ça permet d'éclairer et on
sait à quel point c'est important de le
faire les sujets agricoles des sujets
européens parce qu'ils sont tout à fait
im bririqué de façon importante je dis
souvent que la politique agricole
commune c'est une des politiques les
plus intégrées c'est d'ailleurs une des
politiques fondatrice puisqu'on a fêté
ces ces 60 ans l'année passée et j'y
étais à Strasbourg alors je voulais
juste vous dire quelques éléments à la
fois de ce qui se passe dans l'actualité
législative ça me permettra actuel de ce
que je sens aussi du
fonctionnement de la commission et des
sujets agricoles et puis peut-être
évidemment un élément important qui qui
ne va pas lasser de nous occuper je
pense qui est le sujet de la perspective
des négociations comme vous l'avez dit
c'est un processus long d'adhésion avec
l'Ukraine alors d'abord vous dire que
sur la question de l'activité min
ministérielle et sur la
question européenne sur les des textes
législatifs premier élément il me semble
qu'on on a besoin nous Français de
penser la relation avec les autres
partenaires européens comme une relation
de de à la fois de compromis dialogue
avec les autres je dis souvent qu'on
peut avoir raison mais quand on a raison
tout seul à 27 ça sert pas
fondamentalement à grand-chose et donc
j'ai beaucoup nourri des relations
bilatérales avec mes collègues en
Espagne en Italie en Allemagne et je
continuerai à le faire je verrai
prochainement mon collègue polonais je
vous dirai pourquoi je veux le faire
d'ailleurs sur un certain nombre de
questions et j'ai été en Suède enfin
bref il me semble que le sujet européen
mérite qu'on s'y attache parce que c'est
de ce dialogue là que se nourrissent
aussi parfois des compromis que nous
pouvons emener à notre sur la ligne que
nous défendons il me semble que c'est un
élément important alors plusieurs textes
qui sont passés vous je sais plus sinon
je crois pas que vous l'z évoquer mais
un qui est un peu derrière nous mais Don
je veux quand même dire ces effets c'est
la directive sur les émissions
industrielles d directive
IED j'avais une stratégie qui est qui
était pas tout à fait àignée avec celle
de la profession nous reconnaissons-le
il y avait IOD c'est la directive
émission industrielle comme vous le
savez il y a plein de sujets dedans et
dedans il y a des sujets agricoles dans
les sujets agricoles il y avait déjà
aujourd'hui des prod deux productions
qui étaient c'était la le port et la
volaille le sujet c'était de baisser les
seuils qui obligeaent à rentrer dans
cette directive qui vise à faire un
certain nombre de contrôle et deuxième
sujet c'était d'abaisser les seuils pour
ceux qui étaient déjà et d'intégrer
éventuellement les beauvins j'avais une
stratégie de seuil qui soit suffisamment
élevé pour que ça ne modifie pas
profondément les équilibres sur les
élevages déjà exist mais qui permettait
de faire rentrer par ailleurs le bovin
et en gros les chiffres que nous avions
c'était que ça faisait rentrer entre 100
et 300 élevages bovvin en France et moi
il me semblait que cette stratégie
permettait de démontrer que nous avions
un modèle de production agricole en
filière animale qui était un modèle
moins industriel encore que je crois pas
que l'industrie soit so un gros mot mais
moins industriel que d'autres pays
compris dans les équilibres entre la
production et les équilibres dans les
territoires malheureusement le texte du
compromis issu du trilogue n'est pas
tout à fait celui-là puisque il a été
exclu les bovins c'était la demande
d'une partie de la profession euh et
donc l'accord s'est fait en excluant les
bovins mais en abaissant tellement les
ses que ça va faire rentrer un certain
nombre de de comment dirais-je d'élevage
de por et de volaill et que c'est une
contrainte importante même si c'est un
horizon qui est plutôt 2028 2029 et 2030
mais c'est des contraintes
supplémentaires pour comment dirais-je
agrandir son élevage ou créer un élevage
exnilo et donc il y a un élément de
vigilance on va essayer de faire en
sorte que il y ait quelque chose qui
soit fait d'avoir une une une approche
différenciée selon la taille quand même
même s'il y a déjà un seuil pour faire
en sorte que les types d'élevage couvert
ne bénéficient pas quand vous avez euh
100000 volailles c'est pas comme quand
vous en avez 20000 et donc il faut quand
même qu'on arrive à trouver une voie de
différenciation le trilogue a abouti il
va y avoir un vote maintenant on verra
si le vote abouti parce qu'on est dans
un moment européen que je n'ai pas
besoin de vous décrire où les positions
et les mouvements sont tout à fait
différents quand on débute le mandat que
quand on finit le mandat et on voit bien
les positionnements qui sont un peu
nouveaux restauration de la nature c'est
un règlement aussi qui a été sur la
table qui a été beaucoup débattu moi
j'ai profondément euh rejeté l'idée que
euh restauration de la nature c'est pas
retour à l'état de nature or il y avait
dans les principes qui était de dire
dans certaines zones il y a plus en gros
de fertilisation il y a plus d'engrais
il y a plus de produits phytosanitaire
ce qui revenait quand même d'une
certaine façon à mettre sous cloche une
grande partie du territoire sous un
concept déjà un peu compliqué qu'on
retrouve après dans la la réglementation
sûre qui est les zones sensibles les
zones Natura 2000 enfin bref et qui
aboutissaent quand même à faire en sorte
que dans toute une partie du territoire
on ne puisse plus avoir de production
agricole on y aurait pu y rajouter
d'ailleurs la question forestière en
première intention texte a été retiré
puis il a la partie agricole a été
retirée puis remis au final dans
l'accord final qui a été trouvé dans le
trilogue là aussi d'ailleurs mais avec
une version tout à fait amoindrie qui je
crois n'inquiète plus grand monde après
faud regarder quand même dans le détail
comment ça se tout ça se s'incrémente
territoire par territoire il me semble
que c'est
c'est c'est ça qu'il faut vérifier il y
avait quand même un sous-jacant je le
dis dit mais ça me permettra de finir
là-dessus si vous me permettez il y
avait un sous-jacent qui est le Green
Deal peut pas être pour moi le Green
Deal de la décroissance or il y avait un
sous-jacent mais je sais bien euh il y
avait un sous-jacent dans ce texte qui
était quand même un sous-jacent
décroissant quand vous dites je prive
une partie des moyens des intrants et
des facteurs de production des
territoires vous vous retrouvez dans la
situation
oui et donc bon l'équilibre est pas trop
mauvais reconnaissons-le c'est un
compromis qui n'est pas mais il faudra
être vigilant sur la mise en lèv trème
point ça me permet de répondre tout de
suite là-dessus sur la question des
techniques
génomiques alors je ne délis pas tout à
tout à fait de la réglementation sûre
parce qu'on est dans un mouvement un peu
compliqué au niveau européen c'était
noué une forme d'accord entre les
parlementaires entre les président de
commission agricole et environnement qui
était dire on fait la réglementation
sûre et on fait la réglementation NBT
NGT puisque NBT NGP NGT viennent en écho
apporter des solutions à une trajectoire
de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires le texte sûr a été euh
pardon du terme shoter je sais pas
comment rejeté c'est plus c'est plus
académique d'un point de vue juridique
il a été rejeté sans qu'on voit vraiment
de perspective pour le pour le faire
mais il me semble je me permet de faire
sûr tout de suite que nous avons intérêt
nous Français contenu de l'expérience
qu'on a c'est-à-dire une expérience
plutôt où on n pas de cadre européen et
on fait un peu chacun ce qu'il veut et
les Français sont pas exemp de
surtransposition depuis des dizaines
d'années sur un certain nombre de sujets
moi je trouvais que ce qui pouvait y
avoir intéressant dans sûr c'est d'avoir
une réglementation harmonisée sur la
question des produits phytosanitaires
c'est que tout le monde passe à la même
toiss sachant que nous n'avons pas de
retard par rapport à d'autres sur le
sujet premier élément deuxème élément
que sur les autorisations de mise en
marché les analyses sur les produits
phyos on est une réglementation qui soit
plus européenne que nationale parce que
sinon chacun fait aussi un peu ce qu'il
veut et il me semble que c'est plus
intéressant il compris qu'on a une forme
d'harmonisation là-dessus il restait un
sujet important sur qui qui a fait
échouer en partie c'est une partie de ça
qui a fait achouer l'accord c'est le
fait que là aussi dans un certain nombre
de zones sensibles je pense là aussi aux
zones Natura 2000 on expliquait queil y
aurait aucun produit phyosanitaire
immédiatement et donc il y avait une
bascule qui était tout à fait impossible
j'ajoute un dernier élément c'est que je
ne voyais pas les outils financiers pour
accompagner cette trajectoire ça m'amène
là-dessus à la question de la position
de la France la position de la France
dans la cadre du Plan écofyo je pense
qu'on a pas intérêt à en rabattre sur la
question de trouver des alternatives aux
produits phytosanitaires pour plusieurs
motifs c'est que euh premièrement la
majorité des produits qu'on voit
disparaître c'est parce que les les
firmes ne demandent pas la
réautorisation de mise sur le marché
parce qu' trouvent que le marché
européen est trop petit que finalement
les terrains d'expansion au Brésil en
Ukraine en Russie et ailleurs sont des
terrains beaucoup plus intéressants pour
eux que les procès sont beaucoup Simp
plus simples dans ces pays-là que dans
nos pays européens et donc souvent on
assiste à un retrait des molécules de on
a des retraits des molécules qui sont
produits par l'fsa pour des raisons que
parfois on identifie pas aujourd'hui et
que demain on pourra identifier des
raisons de santé publique qui peuvent
apparaître et donc de toute façon on a
intérêt à trouver des alternatives aux
produits phytosanitaires soit des
produits phytosanitaires qui sont avec
moins d'effet sur l'environnement ou sur
la santé quand c'est le cas ou des des
produits des produits alternatifs des
systèmes de biocontrôle qui permettent
de le faire c'est là que j'arrive
arrivverit après sur NBT NGT mais il me
semble que en Rabatt sur cette question
là évidemment maintenant il y a plus un
élément contraignant au niveau européen
donc il faut regarder ça avec ce regard
là mais qu'on se fixe une trajectoire et
qu'on essaie de trouver des des des
systèmes d'alternatives là-dessus ça me
paraît un élément évidemment très
important pour pour crédibiliser une
démarche il me semble que c'est un
élément quand même on peut pas dire on
fait une trajectoire il y a pas de
règlement on continue on a une
trajectoire continue je pense que c'est
notre intérêt et c'est l'intérêt des
agriculteurs he je le dis de se préparer
à vos alternatives même si évidemment il
faut des systèmes plus combinatoires et
j'en arrive aux techniqu
génomique on a un texte qu'on a beaucoup
poussé nous c'est de faire en sorte
qu'on ait un débat très vite avant les
élections européennes donc les Espagnols
ont beaucoup poussé avec nous enfin
c'est nous qui avons poussé avec les
Espagnols parisils avaient la présidence
la mise à l'ordre du jour comme on dit
de l'agenda de des techniques des ngtnbt
nous avons eu un tour de table lundi
dernier c'était au Conseil effec enfin
lundi oui dernier pas pas dernier
précédent la semaine dernière qui a
permis d'avoir un tour de table qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a quand même encore
une minorité de blocage sur le texte
allemande et plutôt pays de l'Est alors
les uns sur la question du rapport au
bio les autres sur parfois la question
de la breuv
stabilité les troisè sur les questions
d'étiquetage ou de il y a deux
catégories qui ont été créées sur les
les nouvelles techniques gonomiques la
première catégorie on les considère
comme des variétés plus classiques et
donc ne relève pas des OGM et puis les
deuxièmes relèvent des OGM et de la
réglementation ogogm donc on n pas
aujourd'hui un accord et ça va être
transmis maintenant à la Présidence
belge is qu'on est le le 19 décembre
l'objectif c'est que dans les 6 mois
c'est-à-dire dans les 3 mois on trouve
un accord et c'est pour ça que je me
rendrai assez prochainement dans un
certain nombre de pays européens qui
sont aujourd'hui dubitatifs pour leur
expliquer essayer de leur expliquer
l'intérêt de ces techniques elles sont
intéressantes pour les produits phyos
elles sont intéressantes aussi pour les
questions de dérèglements climatiques
euh les nouvelles techniques génémiques
on peut pas se priver nous quand tous
les pays du monde sont en train de s'en
servir on sont en train de le développer
d'une technique qui est très puissante
puisqueen fait ça vient accélérer des
processus naturels puisque c'est une
technique génomique à l'intérieur d'un
même génome d'une même plante mais on
sait qu'on peut accélérer de certains
disent de plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'années c'est-à-dire des adaptations
qui se feraient sur le terrain sous la
contrainte des maladies ou s la
contrainte du climat elles sont
accélérées parce qu'on vient exprimer un
gène par une technique de de coupure je
rentre pas dans les détails ça n'a pas
d'intérêt et je ne suis pas biochimiste
encore mais il me semble que c'est
important de dire que nous avons cette
position là qui est une position
importante parce que le pas
d'interdiction sans solution alors les
interdictions ne produisent pas les
solutions mais l'absence de cherche de
de recherche sur les solutions est un
vrai problème et la nouvelle technique
génomique peut le faire j'ai bon espoir
qu'on arrive à trouver un accord n on
est il y a deux ou trois pays à aller
chercher pour essayer de trouver une
majorité qui permette d'avoir un texte
sur lequel pourrait s'exprimer alors on
a un rapport de force désormais
parlementaire qui dit j'ai pas eu la
réglementation sûde n'y aura pas la
réglementation sur les techniques
génémiques je trouve que cette stratégie
est une stratégie du pire euh euh à la
vérité d'ailleurs le ministre Béchu l'a
dit lui-même c'est à force de vouloir
euh les plus extrêmes V vouit une te un
règlement sur trit virulent et les
autres voulaient rien résultat on a rien
en fait et donc je pense que c'est
dommage et sur les techniques génomiques
j'aimerais bien qu'on ait quelque chose
qui soit équilibré on a quelque chose de
plutôt équilibré la Commission et la
présidence espagnole a plutôt répondu à
un certain nombre de questionnements que
nous avions sur le sujet il me semble
qu'on doit pouvoir trouver un terrain
d'entente à nous de convaincre
maintenant les deux ou trois pays qui
aujourd'hui pourrai faire blocage pour
empêcher que les choses de se fassent ça
me permet de répondre d'ailleurs aussi
sur la question du glyphosate non je
suis pas à l'aise enfin je suis pas mal
à l'aise avec la position qui a été
prise sur le gphosat je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que j'essaie de mettre
dans la situation dans laquelle j'étais
quand j'étais élu local c'est vous avez
un texte qui est posé avec lequel vous
n'êtes pas radicalement en opposition
mais qui ne va pas aux objectifs que
vous étiez fixé sur la question du
glyphosate qu'est-ce qu'elle avait été
la position de la France depuis ces
dernières années la position de la
France c'était de faire en sorte que
partout où on pouvait trouver des
alternatives on les on les trouve on les
accompagne et que pour le reste on
utilise le glyphosate on pense à
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
qui est un c'est un herbicide dont on a
besoin sur l'agriculture de conservation
des sols ou dans les territoires
fortement escarp ou la seule solution
pour déserver c'est le glyphosate donc
la position de la France elle a pas
changé avec la décision de la Commission
européenne finale et par ailleurs dans
le débat j'ai essayé d'emmener un
certain nombre de collègues pour dire on
réautorise le glyphosate mais partout on
peut réduire réduisons sachant que il y
a certains sujets sur lesquels on a
encore des doute pas les sujets de santé
parce que moi je considère que l'ANA euh
l'EFSA doublé de l'ANS d'ailleurs hein a
dit que c'est les éléments ne lui
permettai pas de dire que de conclure à
ce qu'il y a un risque sur la santé il y
a des éléments qui restent en suspens
sur les questions de biodiversité donc
partout où on peut réduire réduisons euh
et partout où on en a encore besoin
gardons-le c'était ça la solution
pragmatique que nous proposion qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire désormais on va se tenir
à ce qu' était la position française je
je j'alerte sur le fait que revenir
j'entends que certains nous disent bah
la loi européenne rien que la loi
européenne parce qu'en fait vous
reconduisez une surtransposition oui
alors d'abord je suis soucieux comme
vous des donners publiques on a quand
même mis deux fois ou trois fois 7
millions d'euros en en crédit d'impôt
pour accompagner ceux qui qui
s'engageaient euh qui s'engageaient sur
la réduction du glyphosate ou qui
sortaiit du glyphosate sur leurs
exploitations faire ça c'est vraiment
dire qu'on a gaspillé 20 millions
d'euros moi je trouve que ça serait
regettable et objectivement aujourd'hui
il y a bien des sujets où vous avez sans
doute raison et je partage avec vous où
il y a de la surtransposition qui a créé
de la distorsion globalement les
agriculteurs ont plutôt trouvé la voie
me semble-t-il au au au aux sujets qui
sont les leurs donc voilà pour ces
questions euh glyphosate réglementation
sûre et cetera je finis juste pour la
question euh européenne plus globalement
d'abord on est en première année de mise
en œuvre de la nouvelle pâack ce qui est
toujours un moment un peu complexe pour
ceux qui se souviennent de 2015 où il y
a
eu un mauvais soir c'est un peu un
passage à l'an 2000 qui s'est passé sur
la pack de 2015 puisqueil y a un certain
nombre de les agcurs ne pouvait pas être
payé sur crédit européen enfin ça été
très très compliqué la pack 2015 c un
souvenir très douloureux pour les
services du
ministère et pour les agriculteurs on a
procéder au paiement dans un dans un
calendrier qui était plutôt assez
resserré alors avec des éléments
nouveaux écorégime
sous la forme qu'il est présente dans
laquelle il est présenté là et puis
aussi à la demande en particulier des
jeunes agriculteurs le fait de mieux
définir l'agriculteur actifs pour que on
ne vienne pas apporter des subventions
pack à des agriculteurs qui ne seraient
pas réellement desactifs dans le process
ça a pu ralentir un certain nombre de
paiements mais je pense que ça s'est
payé ça s'est passé dans de bonnes
conditions et puis j'en termine pour pas
être trop long ça permettra d'avoir un
certain nombre d'élément je dis juste
sur la pack elle est quand même un
élément d'évolution au travers des
écorégimes on me dit souvent parfois
certains nous reprochent en disant mais
c'est pas la p est pas assez verte il y
a elle n'engage pas assez des
transitions enfin la conditionnalité
elle engage plein de transitions la
rotation des cultures les couverts
intercultures les éléments fixes de
biodiversité tout ça c'est des éléments
qui viennent engager l'agriculture dans
la la grande transition qui est la
sienne il me semble que c'est un élément
important et puis je finis juste par la
perception que j'ai c'est un peu votre
questionnement sur la façon dont
fonctionne l'Union européenne dans le
cadre agricole moi je vais vous donner
un sentiment qui est un sentim
al je suis plus au rapport d'étonnement
parce que maintenant il y a trop
longtemps que je suis à ce poste un je
suis frappé de voir la lenteur des
décisions dans l'espace européen
je quand même la conviction là c'est une
conviction personnelle que tout cela a
été fait pour les temps de paix et de
prospérité pas fait beaucoup pour les
temps de guerre et désordre du monde et
donc je ne peux pas avoir sur ces
décisions là comment dirais-je parfois
une commission européenne qui dit on
vous parlera dans 6 mois dans 9 mois
dans 12 mois ou je ne peux pas changer
le règlement parce que c'est trop
compliqué
parce que c'est les lois de la guerre
sont ce qu'elles sont au sens général la
guerre économique la guerre de
souveraineté alimentaire deuxème élément
je trouve que le Green Deal a été posé à
l'époque dans un cadre qui n'était pas
celui dans lequel nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui dans l'intervalle il s'est
passé de trois petites choses j'appelle
ça le covid la guerre en Ukraine les
crises alimentaires ou le dérèglement
des sujets alimentaires plus la mise en
en perspective que la dérèglement
climatique allait produire des effets
absolument toxiques sur l'équilibre et
sécurité alimentaire et donc l'Europe
doit réinterroger me semble-t-il sa
politique dans ce cadre-là et je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui on a du mal alors j'ai vu
les initiatives qui a prise qui ont été
pris par la présidente V derleyen je lui
fais pas Griff mais à 6 mois d'un
échéance électorale c'est pas là qu'on
va faire j'ai peur qu'on ait du mal à
travailler sur ce sujet-là sereinement à
6 mois d'une échéance électorale mais
l'Europe doit se
réinterroger je le disais l'autre jour
au commissaire européen on peut pas nous
dire qu'on doit rien changer quand si on
ne voit pas ce qui s'est passé par
exemple sur la question énergétique et
on est en train si on prend garde de
prendre le même chemin sur la question
alimentaire si on se prive et des moyens
de production et des moyens de produire
je donne juste un chiffre l'an dernier
l'Europe a importé 20 millions de tonnes
de céréales cette année elle va importer
40 millions de tonnes de céréales c'est
un problème ce qui a justifié que j'ai
pris une initiative seule français moi
France si je peux dire nous France sur
la question desjà chers en disant qu' on
pouvait pas dans ce système là continuer
à dire et et à entretenir une forme
d'utopie sur ces bienens d'avoir 4 % s
jacher quand on n'est pas capable de
couvrir ses propres besoins deuxième
élément je trouve que l'Europe ne se
pense pas comme puissante sur la
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
parce que le sujet c'est non seulement
de nourrir sa propre population et nous
n'en prenons pas tout à fait de chemin
avec les éléments que je vous donne sous
la contrainte climatique ou s la sous
d'autres contraintes et de l'importantci
c'est de savoir qui je nourris à mes
frontières qui nourrit mes frontières
qui nourrit le bassin méditerranéen
parce que c'est pas la même chose si
c'est nous que si c'est les Russes pour
dire les choses un peu plus directement
et ça m'amène au dernier point c'est la
question ukrainienne on a lancé les
négociations d'adhésion vous le savez
mieux que moi c'est des négociations qui
par
nature sont longues notamment l'acquis
ce qu'on appelle l'acquis communautaire
mais vous savez tout ça par cœur et
l'acquis communautaire il va s'appliquer
aussi à l'agriculture c'est qu'on peut
pas faire rentrer un pays qui ne
s'appliquerait pas les mêmes règles les
Ukrainiens le savent et j'ai été leur
dire pas plus tard qu'il y a un mois et
demi deuxième élément c'est vrai que
c'est une puissance agricole
immense alors la question qui va se
poser maintenant d'ailleurs à vrai dire
elle se pose quel que soit euh comment
dirais-je quelle que soit l'équation
adhésion ou pas adhésion nous avons à
nos frontières un voisin très puissant
d'un point de vue agricole est-ce qu'on
s'en fait un allié pour que l'Europe à
27 ou à
29 décide de dire la puissance
alimentaire je vais la faire nous
n'avons pas aujourd'hui les capacités à
27 d'avoir une puissance alimentaire
comme pourrait nous apporter une
puissance alimentaire ukrainienne mais
ça ne marche que si on le fait dans une
logique de puissance collective et pas
dans une logique de l'Ukraine qui
viennent sur nos marchés euh
au fond abattre ou mettre à mal notre
agriculture or aujourd'hui c'est la
première fois et c'est pour ça que ça
doit nous interroger je pense que le
sujet et donc est-ce qu'on fait de
l'Ukraine quelque chose un pays qui avec
nous vient conquérir les marchés sur
lesquels sont aujourd'hui les Russes les
brésilien l'espace américain il
peut-être une autre option qui est celle
qui vienent n concurrencer sur les
marchés ça c'est un risque je reconnais
qui est un risque immense et donc on a
besoin oui on
l'a on l' oui c'est pour ça qu' oui on
l'a vécu là vous avez raison et donc
donc donc voilà par je suis un peu long
mais il me semble que juste ça cette
question il faut il faut la travailler
avec les Ukrainiens de toute façon ils
sont là de c'est la première fois qu'on
va faire rentrer ou qu'on on a la
perspective que qui est de notre sphère
d'influence un pays qui sur les
questions agricoles entre plus productif
que nous plus compétitif que
nous je sais pas si j'imagine que
certains d'entre vous ont été en Ukraine
c'est la structure des exploitations et
le
sol c'est quand même un eldorado un
eldorado dans lequel
dans lequel il y a beaucoup de Français
qui sont allés d'ailleurs pour dire les
choses très clairement euh et donc on a
besoin de dire que ça existe c'est pas
parce qu'on il rentre ou il rentre pas
que ça change quelque chose sur le fait
que ça existe et qu'on a besoin de s'en
faire des alliés pour en pour que il
viennent pas de toute façon sur nos
marchés avec des distorsions de
concurrence qui seraient trop fortte
voilà un peu comme j'essaie d'aborder le
chemin est assez long euh il y a
beaucoup d'opérateurs privés en Ukraine
donc ils ont une politique agricole qui
est très puissamment portée par des
opérateurs privés dont l'intérêt est
plutôt immédate moyen long terme et moi
je pense qu'avec les autorités
ukrainiennes il faut leur dire essayons
de penser long terme parce que votre
sujet c'est pas la France votre sujet
c'est l'Afrique euh votre sujet c'est
c'est c'est l'Asie et votre sujet c'est
la concurrence avec les Brésiliens parce
que vous avez une structure qui vous
permet de le faire voilà ce que je
voulais juste vous dire sur les
différents sujets que vous avez abordés
et que nous prolongons peut-être par des
questions merci Monsieur le Ministre
juste un petit point avant de passer la
parole à mes collègue c'est dire que sur
sur le Green Deal en particulier nous
n'avons eu de cess aussi de de de
demander à la Commission de nous fournir
des études d'impact de ce qu'allait être
le Green Deal sur l'agriculture
française la seule la seule étude qu'on
a pu mettre en exerg c'est une étude
américaine qui nous disait que les
productions allaiit baisser de 10 à 15
%. pourquoi pourquoi l'Union européenne
à un certain moment n'a pas et peut-être
sous l'égite de la France n'a pas voulu
ou produire d'études ou faire des études
qui auraient quand même facilité le
dialogue et peut-être êre la
compréhension des acteurs sur nos
territoires c'est une simple question à
laquelle vous répondez ou vous répondez
pas je j'ai la même question vous c'est
ça que je réponds et donc c'est grave
mais c'est c'est collectivement embêtant
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a on
n' pas accepté un certain nombre de
disposition je penseant la
réglementation sûr c'est que je on est
on n'est pas capable de nous donner des
chiffres crédibles de ce que ça donne en
terme de production on continue à les
aller sur les objectifs le problème
c'était les moyens quoi oui mais sur le
Green Deal je personne ne sait très
crédiblement ce que ça donne en terme de
production et ça votre question et mais
je suis c'est embêtant parce que c'est
quand même la Commission européenne qui
dispose d'un certain nombre de moyens
d'étude et et ça nourrit une querelle et
une crainte qui est de dire en fait vous
nous cachez quelque chose ça c'est alors
ils ont fait une étude ça m'a permis du
coup ils ont donné un élément mais sans
qu'on a des éléments tangibles en disant
la réglementation sûre ça réduirait la
production viticole de 30 % mais c'est
pas très grave bon les deux sujets
nétaient 1 30 % c'est beaucoup et de
c'est très grave oui et donc je trouve
que de ce point de vue-là mais c'est le
sujet qu'on a c'est pour ça al je
reviens 2 secondes au National le sujet
de la
planification est un sujet important
parce que ça permet de mettre en
adéquation vous avez des objectifs
environnmentaux est-ce qu'il viennent
ils viennent couvrir vos objectifs de
souveraineté est-ce qu'il viennent
couvrir vos objectifs de production et
cetera et cetera parce qu'en fait si on
met on confronte pas ces points de vue
là on peut toujours déclamer qu'on veut
réduire si ou ça comme facteur de
production à la fin on n'arrive pas à
produire mais c'est une des fragilités
moi je trouve devant les opinions
publiques en particulier devant les
agriculteurs c'est pour ça que nous
sommes à chaque fois à dire nous voulons
des études qui nous permettent de dire
qu'est-ce qui se
passe merci alors on commence la série
de questions je vous propose qu'on les
prenne par trois monsieur le ministre ça
vous facilitera probablement la tâche on
commence par Cyril pelva puis se prépare
Jacques
ferernck merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre ma question porte
sur la proposition de directive sur la
surveillance des sols présenté par la
Commission européenne en juillet qui
comprend des dispositions sur les
principes de G g durable des terres
agricoles or la mise en œuvre des
mesures de gestion durbl des sols
pourrait représenter des coûts
importants pour les agriculteurs comme
pour l'État je souhaitais donc savoir
quelles sont les actions mises en œuvre
par le ministère de l'agriculture en
matière de gestion durable des sols et
dans quelle mesure les normes relatives
aux bonnes conditions agricoles et
environnementales ont-elles contribué à
améliorer à une amélioration des
pratiques agricoles par ailleurs
pensez-vous qu'il fait renforcer leur
niveau d'ambition pour atteindre les
objectifs défin dans la nouvelle
stratégie de l'UE en matière de sol je
vous
remercie
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre j'aimerais d'abord revenir
donc sur la déréglementation vous l'avez
évoqué des nouvelles technique génomique
d NTG donc la France soutient le
compromis de Madrid sur le texte la
commission ce texte visa à assouplir les
règles de mise sur le marché et de mise
en culture pour certaines NTG ces
nouveaux OGM qui permettent si j'ai bien
compris de sélectionner des semen était
jusqu'ici interdit dans l'Union
européenne donc si ce compromis est
accepté cela dispenserait pour une des
deux parties de CNTG d'obligation de
contrôle de traçabilité d'étiquetage
parce qu'elle serait considéré comme des
plantes conventionnelles donc la
commission si j'ai bien compris a
concédé certes la réalisation d'une
étude d'impact sur les brevet mais en
2025 soit après l'adoption de la
nouvelle réglementation on sait que les
brevets sont valables 20 ans j'aurais
voulu que le gouvernement est une
position ferme au Conseil contre tout
affaiblissement de la réglementation des
M j'ai compris que ce n'était pas votre
position rapidement sur le Mercosur
là-dessus on est en phase avec la
position du gouvernement qui freine
l'adoption de l'accord juste avant la
COP 28 le Brésil a d'ailleurs voté une
loi qui facilite l'approbation de
nouveaux pesticid donc adopter le
Mercosur dans ces conditions c'est
mettre en péril notre agriculture je
sais que le président a un voyage prévu
au Brésil en mars pour continuer les
négociations on espère qu'il ne cèdera
pas et puis enfin sur l'accord avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande voté le 23 novembre par
les eurodéputés il impactera directement
l'activité de nos éleveurs or les
conditions d'élevage sont pas
équivalentes la Nouvelle-Zélande et la
France en Nouvelle-Zélande il y a pas de
Lou chez nous les éleveurs sont
confrontés à une hausse des coûts de
production imputable au plan contre les
attaques de loup
donc avec cet accord avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande on voit que on peut pas
clamer la souveraineté alimentaire et
passez-moi l'expression envoyez pêtre
nos éleveurs
merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre euh moi
je fais écho et d'ailleurs nous
avons présenté à la commission des
affaires européennes donc une une pprre
ensemble avec donc monsieur Cyril
pelleva mais je vais parler de de
l'autre aspect monsieur peva a développé
l'aspect avec le volet agricole moi je
suis quand même extrêmement inquiète de
cette arlaésienne dont on parle temps
qui nous devrait nous arriver à
l'horizon de 2030 c'est-àdire une
directive européenne sur la protection
des sols je crois que par deà donc les
enjeux agricoles qui ont été évoqués
tout à l'heure il y a quand même
d'autres enjeux en matière notamment
notamment donc de d'aléa climatique et
vous êtes d'ailleurs vous êtes rendu
dans mon département à une période
dramatique pour nous où les pollutions
histor que s'était réveillé et avait en
plus impacté des terres agricoles parce
que lorsque vous avez donc de l'arsenic
qui se déverse donc à proximité de vigne
ou de chamb c'est pas quand même l'idéal
nous en sortons à peine moi je
souhaiterait quand même savoir que
quelle est donc la position donc du
gouvernement si nous sommes offensifs
sur ce sujet de manière à pouvoir enfin
appeler donc cette directive européenne
parce que je rappelle que nous avons une
loi sur l'air nationale une loi sur
l'eau mais on a toujours pas donc de loi
sur les sols eu égard bien sûr à
l'aspect donc propriété privée qui
impacte les sols et qui freine donc la
mise en place de ce type de choses nous
sommes tout à fait conscients des freins
mais je crois que c'est un sujet donc
extrêmement important donc moi
j'aimerais donc que par rapport à la
gestion durable donc que vous nous
exposiez votre position entre ce juste
équilibre entre donc les ambitions
agricoles et les ambitions liées à
l'environnement parce que il est vrai
que vivre sur des sols sains pour les
populations c'est quand même extrêmement
important autant que l'air qu'on respire
ou l'eau que que nous
buvons merci beaucoup donc de sujets je
vais faire NBT NGT les accords etin
trois ça fait et puis la question sur
les sols je commence par la question sur
les sols al d'abord je crois pas du tout
que ça ce qu'on qu' faille opposer qui
je pense ça serait une erreur de opposer
la question de la santé des sols et la
question de la production
agricole on sait qu'une partie de la
baisse de production agricole est liée à
une santé des sols qui s'est
dégradé et on a besoin de travailler sur
la qualité des sols la matière organique
on a parfois un
peu oublié que quand même la ce sur quoi
on plante ça compte beaucoup dans la
capacité à produire et quand vous
regardez à facteur de production
quasiment égaux la productivité agricole
française elle a plutôt diminué pour
raison d'usure des sols la matière
organique est moins présente on a sans
doute trop labouré c'est pour ça qu'on a
besoin de techniques simplifié c'est
pour ça qu'on a besoin d'ailleurs de
glyphosate et cetera et cetera donc on a
besoin et c'est là qu'il y a d'ailleurs
une paradoxe parce que c'est quoi la
santé des sols c'est ce qu'il y a dans
les sols qu' don on considère qu' serait
toxique pour tel ou tel ou c'est la
santé c'est-à-dire la capacité quelle
est la fonction qu'on donne au sol c'est
une fonction de purification ou c'est
une fonction de production c'est un
support de la production ou c'est
support de production et autre chose et
attention à ce qu'on est pas pour
répondre à votre question dans les les
réglementations européennes c'est
là-dessus qu'on est très vigilant alors
on n'est pas tout de suite au texte on
va ça va débattre un peu cette affaire
quelque chose qui vienent de nouveau en
travé qui fasse qu'à la fin on vient
dire bah il y a ça ne va tellement pas
sur les sols qu'en fait on produit plus
sur les sols et qu'il faudit revenir
c'est la
même rhtorique qui est au bout en stock
si je peux dire qui est une rhétorique
de moins on est moins on a d'activité
agricole mieux on se porterait d'un
point de vue environnemental et donc
c'est ça qu'il faut battre en brèche
mais est une chose de refuser ça est une
autre de dire on a besoin des de sols
qui soi en bonne santé parce que la
santé des sols c'est une un sol avec de
la biodiversité un sol avec de la
matière organique c'est un sol qui va
être mieux pour la production agricole
j'ajoute un troisième élément c'est que
la santé des sols et l'intégration de la
matière organique c'est une
façon de stocker du carbone l'initiative
qui Ava été prise par un un ancien
prédécesseur un prédécesseur qui est
Stéphan Lefol on sait qu'avec qu'on
appela l'initiative 4 pour 1000 est une
initiative qui qui vise à ré intégrer de
la matière organique dans les sols et ça
a un vrai intérêt parce que ça permet de
stocker du carbone donc il me semble que
il faut pas se délier de la santé des
sols mais la santé des sols pour
stériliser la capacité à produire et que
ce soit la réponse je pense que c'est
une erreur c'est le risque qu' peut y
avoir dans une réglementation comme
celle-là en revanche une santé des sols
qui vient de se préoccuper une santé des
sols au service de la production ça peut
être une trajectoire et donc c'est cet
équilibre là qu'il faut tenir on peut
pas demander tout à la fois il faut
d'abord qu'on retrouve une fonction de
production dans les sols et une certaine
partie des une certaine d'une certaine
façon les pratiques agricoles que ça
cite sont plutôt également vertueuses
d'un point de vue environnemental parce
que vous avez plus de micro-organismes
vous avez plus de vie dans les sols vous
avez plus de carbone stocké et vous avez
plus de production en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je l'aborderai NBT NGT
alors d'abord ce ne sont pas des ogegm
au sens de la définition qu'ils avaient
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu' y a une
réglementation spécifique c'est le débat
qu'on avait que vous avez avec moi et
que nous avons avec d'autres sur le
question de est-ce que les NBT NGT sont
un OGM à notre sens nous non mais c'est
pas nous qui disons principalement c'est
c'est là aussi il faut essayer de
regarder ce que dit la science quels
sont les sujets qu'on a devant nous le
sujet c'est c'est tellement pas quelque
chose d'atypique que on a on aura du mal
à distinguer un produit qui soit NBT
d'un produit qui soit le produit de la
nature ça prouve bien à quel point on n
pas éloigné d'un cycle naturel très
paradoxal de nous dire il faut étiqueter
parce qu'on veut pouvoir différencier
alors que dans la nature on saura pas le
différencier qu'est-ce qu'on fait on
prend le gène le génome du blé et on
travaille sur génome du blé et on met un
génome résistant du blé à je sais pas
quelle maladie et on l'incrémente mais
c'est blé sur blé ce qui était pas tout
à fait le cas de ce qu'on faisait sur le
maïs par exemple deuxième élément c'est
les OGM en grande partie d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui a fait leur échec elle
venaient servir quoi plutôt
l'utilisation de produits
phytosanitaires puisque je vous rappelle
que c'était résistant aux
herbicides et c'est pas du tout ce qu'on
a dans le texte la France a réussi à
faire en sorte que dans le texte on dise
ça doit
servir le cadre et la le cadre de la
transition c'estàd que ça doit servir la
réduction des produits phyau ou la
résistance au dérèglement climatique qui
est devant nous c'est ça qui est un
élément me semble-t-il très important et
donc on a besoin de réfléchir les choses
les choses ainsi donc essayons de
travailler et ne nous privons pas des
outils parce que la France se vit
parfois comme si elle était sur une île
déserte mais l'Europe ne peut pas être
sur une île déserte parce que si nous
avons des outils formidables pour lutter
contre la baisse de production liée à à
la au dérèglement climatique et que tout
le monde l' sauf nous quand personne ne
pointe de risque personne ne pointe de
risque il me sem que là il faut qu'on
sorte un peu alors le débat OGM c'est
comme le débat glyphosate c'est un débat
un peu
de on a de posture on narrive pas à
sortir du du dogme peut-être des uns ou
des autres donc il faut les on on est
commis d'être dans on est sommé d'être
dans un camp ou dans un autre en fait et
moi je suis pas d'accord avec ça je
pense que ce qui est sur la table est un
compromis qui est acceptable et c'est
pour ça qu'on défend enfin je fini sur
les accords les accords
commerciaux d'abord moi je le dis
compris la question de la souveraineté
j'ai déjà dit dans l'enceinte du Sénat
pour pour qu'il a de la souveraineté
euh il faut qu'on soit en capacité aussi
d'échanger je veux dire il y a beaucoup
de nos filières agricole qui dépendent
quand même dans leur équilibre de la
capacité à exporter le lait les céréales
je parle même pas de la viticulture le
lait les céréales le port donc il faut
quand même qu'on ait c'est débats que je
comprends he mais qu'on est nous
Français une vision qui soit une vision
quand même de on a besoin de commerce
dans le dérèglement climatique on a
besoin de commerce euh moi je le
regrette hein mais en fait on est dans
une situation
comme on n'est pas capable de couvrir
nos besoins par rapport à ce qu'on a
fait en terme de trajectoire un peu
décroissante on est bien content que
d'autres viennent nous nourrir et il y a
des années où on sera bien content de
pouvoir nourrir d'autres donc faut pas
qu'on se prive quand même de l'outil en
même temps ça peut pas se faire
n'importe quelle condition et en
particulier la condition climatique il
me semble que la condition climatique
est un élément très important et que il
faut faire en sorte
que comment dirais-je il faut faire en
sorte que dans les accords à minimal
accord sur le climat soit
possible c'est-à-dire que ça soit
compatible avec l'accord sur le climat
après si on veut que dans les accords ça
soit exactement la même agriculture
évidemment l'agriculture brésilienne
elle a pas les mêmes contraintes et les
mêmes caractéristiques que l'agriculture
française ou que l'agriculture
européenne et donc si on voulait aligner
absolument dans le commerce ça veut dire
qu'on renonce nous à notre capacité
export parce que si nous nous refusons
d'exporter d'autres refuseront qu'on
importe chez eux hein qu'ils exportent
chez nous et d'autres donc on a besoin
de trouver cet équilibre c'est ce qui a
justifié la position sur le Mercosur
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui a justifi
aussi de la position favorable sur la
Nouvelle-Zélande parce que quand même le
système néozélandais pour ceux qui
connaissent c'est un système hyper
extensif hein alors ils sont pas
strictement alignés sur ce qu'on fait
enfin si on considère que le système
néozélandais n'est pas extensif alors ça
veut dire que on a refusé on refuse le
Brésil au titre que c'est très intensif
on peut pas faire l'inverse sur la
question me
semble-t-il qu'on peut pas faire
l'inverse sur la sur la question des
pays qui eux font le chemin parce que
sinon ça veut dire que de postulat on
est contre contre les accords mais il
faut être vigilant effectivement il me
semble que c'est important ceci dit pour
ce qui est de la France elle-même là
c'est même plus la question européenne
la la le vrai sujet de compétitivité
c'est un sujet qui est lié à la
compétition avec les autres pays
européens c'est c'est pas principalement
les accords internationaux qui
aujourd'hui on parle d'accords
internationaux qui n'existe pas le
Mercosur n'existe pas Nouvelle-Zélande
vient d'être voté Australie a été
rejetée il y a que le CTA et le CTA
c'est
positif voilà et d'ailleurs mon collègue
bel je vous diraai que quand il y a des
et vous l'avez auditionné vous direz
quand il y a des accords internationaux
c'est souvent mieux
euh que quand il y en a pas dernier
élément il me semble que on a un travail
à faire de conviction au niveau de la
commission parce que c'est pas au niveau
de la DG Agri qui a un problème c'est la
DG trade comme on dit la DG commerce la
DG commerce a plutôt une vision qu'elle
a toujours eu hein ouverte en disant les
accords les accords les accords et une
vision moins stratégique sur les
questions agricoles que que ça ne
devrait je trouve que la question
alimentaire et la question de la
sécurité alimentaire étant sur le DESS
de la pile il me semble important quand
même euh de faire en sorte que désormais
on pense les accords internationaux dans
une stratégie de sécurité alimentaire de
souviné
alimentaire merci allez 3 2e série
Michael Weber se prépare Florence
blatrix conta
oui euh monsieur le ministre merci
d'abord pour pour cet échange
euh je reconnais vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que les OGM comme le glyphosate
ça peut parfois être des positions
dogmatiques donc ça voudrait dire que
aussi bien vous qui défendez enfin une
position sur glyphosate que moi qui en
défend une autre on peut être dans une
position dogmatique et que ça devrait
nous amener à évoluer les un les uns
vers les autres mais bon ça mériterait
un débat beaucoup plus long que CELI
qu'on a ce soir et oui c'est l'ARD du
compromis et on y est malheureusement
pas encore moi je voulais juste revenir
sur sur le le pacte vert et notamment
sur l'avenir du pacte vert pour l'Europe
et la stratégie de la ferme à la table
pour une alimentation plus saine et plus
durable parce que on a vu ce qu'il en
est sur du Règlement sur l'utilisation
durable des pesticides
qui a été enterré je crois le règlement
sur la restauration de la nature qui est
passé une extrémiste mais avec une
ambition qui est commme amoindrie sur la
restauration des systèmes agricoles et
donc au regard de ces revers comment les
objectifs du pacte vert et notamment les
objectifs qui sont fixés pour
l'agriculture par les stratégies
biodiversité et de lafferme à la table
vont-ils être atteints d'autant que la
France tague d'être un exemple en
matière de transition agroécologique et
que va que comptez-vous mettre en place
pour maintenir les efforts du pacte vert
pour l'Europe et le deuxième sujet qui
est lié bien sûr c'est que actuellement
avec seulement 10 % de surface bio on
est loin du compte aujourd'hui du plan
d'action bio européen qui visait à
consacrer 25 % des terres agricoles à
l'agriculture biologique et on sait que
cela a un impact en tout cas sur la
filiia bio en France puisque si je fais
référence notamment à ce qui était prévu
dans le cadre de la loi égalim où on
visait 20 % de produits bio en
restauration collective on est
aujourd'hui à 6 % et que donc là encore
quels sont euh les moyens qui permettrai
d'atteindre ces objectifs là et qui sont
aussi en lien avec une stratégie qui est
une stratégie je crois européenne si ce
n'est au risque de mettre en avant
peut-être plus la démarche HVE mais je
suis pas certain qu'elle soit aussi
exemplaire que la démarche bio donc
merci pour vos élément de
réponse merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre donc en 2021 la
Cour des comptes européennes avait
relevé que la politique agricole
2014-2020 ne respectait pas les
engagements européens en matière
d'utilisation durable de l'eau notamment
les recommandation de la directive cadre
haut et donc
euh ma question est la suivante en
réponse au rapport spéciale de la Cour
des comptes européennes de 2021 comment
la PAC
2023-2027 remédie-elle aux lacunes
précédente en ce qui concerne
l'utilisation durable de l'eau et plus
précisément comment est-ce qu'elle
encourage une utilisation plus
rationnelle de l'eau notamment en ce qui
concerne les paiements directs aux
agriculteurs et les critères de
conditionnalité sur un deuxième volet
concernant l'eau le volet de la qualité
là encore hein la directive DCF vise à
prévenir et à réduire les pollutions
avec pour objectif un bon état
écologique et par ailleurs la directive
eau potable de 2020 euh redéfinit des
normes essentielles de qualité de l'eau
et euh des règles de transparence
vis-à-vis des consommateurs et on le
voit bien la protection des captages
d'eau est absolument essentielle on a eu
au Sénat en juin dernier on a travaillé
on a fait 80 auditions une mission sur
la gestion durable de l'eau et euh y
compris la FNCCR nous indiquait que
l'objectif de protéger les captages
d'eau c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui environ 3
% des surface agricole était absolument
essentiel donc quelle mesure
comptez-vous prendre pour protéger les
captages d'eau et atteindre les
objectifs et à quelle échéance je vous
remercie
oui merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre just de
questions un peu un peu en marge la
première c'est pour vous conforter sur
le rôle de la volaille avec avec
l'Ukraine notamment ou un un grand
industriel de l'ouest de la Sarte bien
d'annoncer la fermeture de 200
poulaillers à cause
d'importation de volail des autres pays
de l'Est qui risque de de compliquer
enfin Mme fortement fortement le le
augmenter les inquiétudes de du du
milieu agricole le deuxème point
qu'est-ce que vous pensez qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de du march à l'envers de
toutes les communes et le 3oisème point
euh je voulais être sûr que en général
je suis un peu inquiet de l'agrioltaïsme
je suis un peu inquiet de la lorsque je
regarde les cartes communales qui sont
présentées actuellement sur les EnR il y
a une forte de proposition de zon euh de
d'accélération qui concerern des terres
agricole où des agriculteurs arrivent à
l'âge de 50 50 55 ans et qui se disent
ben plutôt que de transmettre mon
exploitation je vais rester peut-être à
la retraite je vais installer des lari
voltaïsme à 2 3000 € l'hectare ou 3000
ou 4000 € l'hectare et je vais vivre
tranquillement avec ma retraite jusqu'au
bout donc je voulais savoir si alors
c'est peut-être en marge des discussions
européennes mais c'est quand même quelqu
chose avec les énergies renouvelables
qui concernent toute l'Europe
Merci à VOUS
euh trois
sujets j'essaie de je réponds à votre
question sur le sur le
glyphosate justement on a essayé de pas
être dogmatique de pas dire c'est blanc
ou c'est noir c'est autorisation ou
interdiction c'est dire partoutù on peut
réduire on le fait c'est ça je pense une
position qui ne serait pas dogmatique et
je fais pas de GR parce que c'est devenu
un totem de combat vous voyez ce que je
veux dire
donc personne ne celui qu'il veut le
veut totalement et celui qu' ne veut pas
ne veut pas totalement et il faudrait
qu'on arrive à sortir de ce débat là
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire et c'est
ce qui nous est reproché d'ailleurs mais
partout on peut en en sortir on en sort
deuxième élément alors ces deux
questions qui sont un peu délié mais
vous parlez des question d'eau
mais attention quand même je jamais
quand on pose ces questions là on pose
la question de est-ce qu'avec tout ça on
est capable de produire et c'est un peu
la question queés posait le président
Rapin parce que moi personne ne me
montre aujourd'hui j'ai une production
européenne qui est en baisse continue
depuis 10 à 15 ans c'est quand même un
sujet enfin je pardon de cette
expression que j'utilise en ce moment un
peu c'est ils ont les mains propres mais
ils ont pas de
mains c'est pas de moi c'est de Charles
pegy c'està direire que notre système
est parfait mais en fait on je répète je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure 40 millions de
tonnes de céréales qui sont importé
cette année en Europe 40 millions de
tonnes de céréal c'est pas c'est pas
rien 40 millions de tonnes et on est en
train de dire on continue la trajectoire
on on incrémente des contraintes qui
sont déjà existantes du fait du
dérèglement climatique sans se dire
est-ce que tout ça ça même on a sans
compter ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
non ce qu'on a pas encore dit sur il
faut produire plus de biomasse parce que
les biomatériaux les biocombustibles les
bioénergies j'ai besoin de plus de
biomasse donc tout ça à la fois je je le
dis faut je mets en garde au niveau
européen sur quelque chose qui
rapidement va montrer les limites de
l'exercice alors ça m'amène à répondre à
deux donc oui il faut un Green Deal mais
le Green Deal ça peut pas être au dépend
d'un d'un sécurité alimentaire d'il or
pour l'instant on a besoin de documenter
de dire comment on fait en sorte qu'on
ait des outils là les NBT les NGT là des
systèmes qui soient plus productifs
parce que nous ne sommes pas un en plus
nous ne sommes pas un espace à 27 qui
est un espace immense il y a pas tant de
terre que ça les américains ils peuvent
avoir une productiontion à faible
rendement puisqu'ils ont des surfaces
immenses les Brésiliens c'est pareil les
Ukrainiens c'est la qualité des terres
qui leur permet le rendement bon mais
nous nous avons des espaces contraints
et donc nous il y a pas d'autre choix
que d'avoir une une productivité qui est
très haute aut parce que si on baisse la
productivité on baisse la production par
nature et on est dépendant des autres et
donc à un moment il va falloir quand
même qu'on pose la question dans ce
registre là vous dites sur la question
du bio au final oui on a alors la
question c'est pas seulement d'avoir des
politiques publiques la question c'est
que et moi je suis un défenseur du bio
parce que je pense que ça fait partie du
modèle et des comment
dirais-je
euh de la diversification dont on a
besoin sur les territoires faut du bio
faut d'autres cultures mais euh il faut
qu'on ait des consommateurs en face hein
parce que ça faut pas demander à la
puissance publique n compris ni à la
puissance européenne de de faire dans la
PAC ce qui est un problème de
déconsommation parce que sinon nous
rentrons dans un sujet qui est un peu
compliqué d'un point de vue économique
c'està dire c'est la puissance publique
qui doit soutenir la la consommation de
tel ou tel secteur sachant qu'on met en
gros sur la PAC et même les moyens
disponibles nationaux près de 800
millions d'euros sur le La La La le bio
soit le maintien via des dispositifs
fiscaux soit la transition soit la
transition euh la conversion soit sur
des dispositifs euh sur des dispositifs
européens mais il faut qu'on arrive à
rencontrer la la
demande je serais curieux j'ai pas la
réponse mais je vais la faire faire 40
millions de tonnes importé cette année
de céréales si je passe tout en bio ça
fait combien de millions de tonnes
importé en
fait c'est quand même une question qu'il
faut se poser et dire ça c'est pas faire
offense à l'idée qu'on a besoin de bio
par ailleurs et ça pose la question
aussi c'est la même questionnement que
j'ai sur la question de l'eau qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dans la PAC sur la question
de l'eau c'est notamment la question de
de la couvert ure permanente ça permet
de mieux de mieux de mieux stocker enfin
d'éviter les les quce que s'échappe en
particulier les nitrates par exemple
deuxième élément je pense que on
favorise plutôt l'agroécologie le fait
qu'on travaille mieux la rotation des
cultures ça permet de mieux fixer
l'azote ça permet d'avoir moins recours
aux engrais ça permet sans doute d'avoir
des
éléments et qui qui est qui est moins
recours au à l'usage de produits
phytosanitaires et donc ave avec la
question de l'eau mais c'est un
équilibre qu'il faut trouver parce que
je ne sais pas faire sinon je dis les
choses très simplement et donc dans la
pâack les écorégimes en particulier ils
viennent conforter une stratégie qui est
une stratégie de changement d'assolement
d'évolution des assolements et de
réduction des produits phytosanitaire il
me semble que c'est un élément c'est un
élément important dernier sujet enfin
deux sujets monsieur le sénateur sur la
question AG alors agrivoltaïque c'est
moins un sujet
européen on a beaucoup fait en sorte
dans le décret notamment ministère de
l'Agriculture qu'on puisse trouver une
voie
[Musique]
euh qui permettent de pas avoir des
effets comme vous lesz décrivez
opportunisme moi je pense que et donc
d'avoir de vrais projets Agri pour pas
avoir des projets faussement Agri et
plutôt voltaïque que
Agri deuxème élément il y a un principe
de base c'est d'essayer de limiter de
réduire la baisse de production qui est
induite trisème élément je pense que
c'est un sujet sur lequel il faut qu'on
travaille on a besoin de travailler sur
un sujet qui soit de nature différente
c'est la répartition de la valeur par
que la question que vous posez c'est qui
touche et donc si c'est principalement
le propriétaire c'est c'est pas pas la
même oui par que ça peut être le
propriétaire c'est pas la même chose que
si c'est l'agriculteur donc on a besoin
de travailler avec le monde agricole
pour regarder comment on réparti la
valeur ça fera l'objet d'un certain
nombre de de réglementations quand à la
vola sur la question ukrainienne alors
un c'est vrai qu'on a on a on a
libéralisé l'ouverture des frontière au
à la vol ukrainienne considérant que c
faisait une partie de l'effort que nous
faisions moi j'ai demandé au niveau
européen qu'on ait une ouverture qui
soit séquencé qu'on puisse la
réinterroger régulièrement ce qui fait
qu'on la réinterrogera au mois de juin
ce qui manque aussi pardon monsieur le
prés président de redire la deux fois la
même chose j'ai besoin d'une
documentation parce que il y a ce qu'on
me dit et puis ce que je
vois ce qu'on me dit c'est
euh plutôt marginal et puis ce que je
vois c'est que quand même les
importations françaises sont plus
importantes alors elles arrivent de
Belgique des Pays-Bas ou de Pologne mais
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à quoi
ressemble ma volaille si je peux dire
donc on a besoin d'avoir un système
européen qui permette de garantir ce qui
rentre et ce qui sort c'est pas faire
offense aux Ukrainiens que de le dire
c'est juste on a besoin en crédibilité
de le faire de ils ont en profité ils
ont pas voulu profiter mais on a eu un
sujet volac comme vous le savez bien on
a eu un sujet qui est la grippe aviaire
et donc ça ça a lourdement impacté alors
on a beaucoup aidé pour
tenir la structure agricole le mieux
qu'on pouvait les structures agricoles
mais en même temps on a un deuxième
sujet là-dessus c'est que du coup ils
sont engouffrés dans une brêche qui
était une baase de production qui était
structurelle et donc on va réinterroger
la question et quand j' été en Ukraine
j'ai interrogé la question en disant
attention si on veut parler d'adhésion
et qu'on commence par se faire des
croupires comme ça là on va avoir un
sujet de dialogue avec les avec les
agriculteurs français et européens je
pense que c'est bien compris après les
opérateurs c'est au gouvernement
ukrainien aussi de prendre ses
disposition c'est-à-dire
que l'idée c'est de faire en sorte que
les céréales sortent et qu'elles sortent
hors de
l'Europe et que les marchés retrouvent
leur équilibre hors de l'Europe et et
que on vienne pas sur les céréales ou
sur la volaille ou sur le sucre alors le
sucre ça se tient parce que les marchés
sont hauts mais pour l'instant euh que
cela vient déstabiliser les
marchés merci merci chers collègues il y
aura-t-il d'autres questions ou d'autres
ou oui non ça je sais mais dans ceux qui
se sont
non toi aussi oui tu es inscrite dans
ceux qui n'étaient pas inscrit bon ok
donc on va en prendre quatre c'est les
quatre les quatre dernières donc Louis
Vogel et se prépare Alain
cadek monsieur le ministre merci d'être
avec nous ce soir alors vous avez
rappelé tout à l' l'heure qu'on était
dans la première année de mise en œuvre
de la nouvelle PAC la nouvelle PAC c'est
une nouvelle gouvernance avec une
nouvelle répartition des pouvoirs entre
l'État et les collectivités les régions
avec un transfert de moyens sans
précédents de l'État vers les régions
et une arrivée de dossierers énorme
aussi dans certains départements dans
certaines régions le volume des dossiers
engagés après la date du de la décision
de transfert et effectivement transfer
au 1er janvier 2023 et parfois aussi
important voire supérieur à la totalité
du volume de dossier traité entre 2014
et
2019 alors la gestion de de tel stock
entraîne évidemment des retard de
paiement
euh qui sont à l'origine de grandes
difficultés dans les territoires de
mécontentement de la part de nos
agriculteur alors ma question est très
simple que comptez-vous faire pour
remédier atténuer cette situation et
pour faire que on on reparte par le
haut
d'accord d'abord une fois n'est pas
coutume mais ça n'a rien à voir avec la
commission des Affaires
européennesis remercier le le ministre
d'avoir trouvé 180 millions pour les Mac
c'était las que 150 c'est déjà ça je
sais pas où tu les as trouvé mais en
tous les cas félicitations et merci
pour pour ceux qui les attendaient avec
impatience
euh par rapport monsieur par ailleurs
monsieur le ministre tout à l'heure vous
avez évoquer évidemment le l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine en en essayant de nous
expliquer que c'était pareil sur le
marché ENF c'est ce que j'ai
compris que l'Union que que que que
l'Ukraine entre dans l'Union européenne
ou pas ça me semble pas il y a la Pâque
là-dedans alors il y a le marché unique
donc évidemment les les les conditions
sont plus du tout les mêmes
pour l'Ukraine l'Ukraine comme vous
l'avez dit est un est un est un grand
pays agricole et donc ça va poser des
problèmes clairement donc comment vous
l'imaginez bon le processus d'adhésion
comme vous l'avez dit il prend des
années bon sa bien mais cependant il
faut quand même être extrêmement
vigilant h
merci Monsieur le Ministre moi j'ai une
question enfin des remarques concernant
les les nouvelles technologie génomique
j'ai le plaisir d'être rapporteur pour
notre commission sur ce sujet avec mes
collègues grémier et Arnaud on fait
beaucoup d'auditions en ce moment ça
nous occupe beaucoup et plus on partage
assez la viis que plus on avance dans
les audition et plus on met en lumière
des controverses des controverses
scientifiques des controverses
économiques des controverses chez les
scientifiques et chez les parties
prenantes évidemment on s'y attendait
mais mais chez les scientifiques ça
c'est une surprise en tous les cas dans
dans ce qu'on traverse donc euh euh je
la position affirmée que que vous vous
défendez nous me paraît euh très de
manière très transparente un peu en
décalage par rapport aux aux enjeux que
que l'on peut mettre en en
lumière j'avais une autre question
concernant le dialogue stratégique sur
l'avenir de l'agriculture qu'a annoncé
Ursula wander leyon il y a quelques mois
maintenant euh pour la la période qui
arrive je voulais savoir comment euh euh
cette ce dialogue avançait euh et et
comment est-ce que la France se
positionnait dans les mois à venir y
compris dans un cadre où il y a des
échéances électorales européennes et
comment ce dialogue allait se formaliser
dans son format dans son contenu et
comment est-ce que les parlements y
allaient le cas échéant être associés
j'avais une autre petite question sur le
volet exportation et Commerce
international par rapport à à ce qu'on
entend et ce qu'on observe sur les
exportations de la Russie notamment sur
le continent africain il y a des
inquiétudes des organisations
professionnelles françaises qui nous
interrogent sur le respect des règles de
commerce et les
flux les flux importants et puis parfois
étonnant qui sont opérés donc je voulais
savoir si vous aviez des des
informations à ce sujet et puis enfin
question annexe qui n'a pas qui n'est
pas directement liée au sujet européen
mais je voulais aussi relayer l'inqu qui
étude des chercheurs des directeurs de
recherche et des enseignants chercheurs
dans les écoles d'agriculture et et
d'agronomie où on sait on a beaucoup
d'étudiants étrangers qui viennent faire
leur thèses notamment et je voulais
aussi relayer l'inquiétude quant aux
discussions qu'on a sur le projet de loi
asile immigration qui sera aussi un
signal donné aux étudiants et et aux
enseignants chercheurs dans nos
universités dans nos
écoles merci président merci monsieur le
ministre ministre ben écoutez moi ma
question va porter sur les animaux
domestiques en fait je vais partager une
question avec vous et là et je relaie
une question qui m'a été posé pendant
cette audition monsieur le ministre au
sujet de l'additif
E250 le nitrite de sodium qui
semble-t-il aujourd'hui est interdit
enfin ou sera interdit par l'Europe pour
tout ce qui concerne l'alimentation de
nos animaux domestiques chiens et chats
dans les croquette et qui pour autant
reste toujours autorisé pour
l'alimentation humaine et notamment
dans nos charcuteries donc je voulais
savoir quelle était votre position ce
que vous pouvez nous dire à ce sujet et
en plus largement quelle est la position
de la France par rapport à ce sujet donc
de santé publique je vous
remercie je commence par ce sujet qui
est un sujet d'actualité un
peu il n a pas d'interdiction
d'utilisation des nitrites dans les
l'alimentation pour les les chats et les
chiens il y a les structures ont décidé
d'ell-même de retirer les nitrites c'est
c'est pas une interdiction en fait donc
certains sont en train de vendre un truc
qui n'existe pas après c'est t chois des
structures de premierre élément deuxième
élément il nous aura pas échappé pour
pour l'avoir pratiqué sur mes propres
animaux que parfois on peut donner à nos
animaux des des des produits dont peut
penser que nous ne les consommerions pas
nous-mêmes mais comment dirais-je leur
biologie n'étant pas tout à fait la même
que la nôtre ils sont moins soumis au
risque de botulisme et autres qui
justifi l'utilisation des nitrites
troème élément nous sommes fondés je
j'essaie de ne pas avoir
la comment dirais-je l'anè à la carte
les décisions quiand été pris sur les
nitrites sont des décisions qui ont été
éclairées par Lan donc un ce n'est pas
une interdiction européenne mais c'est
les les boîtes les firmes ont décidé de
retirer pour une raison que j'ignore he
mais je vais documenter deuxième élément
pas tout à fait la même structure
d'animaux que nous et troème élément sur
ce qui est de l' nitrite dans les dans
les jambons en partie parulier dans les
charcuteries il y a une décision lanis
qu'on applique avec une tendance à la
réduction parce qu'il faut autant faire
ce peu réduire mais de quand même
toujours une interrogation de santé
publique donc il faut qu'on combine les
deux parce qu'on sait il y a eu un cas
très grave sur du jambons artisanal qui
est lié au fait que il avait pas été
traité au nitrite et qu' a produit du
botulisme ou je sais plus ce qu'il a
produit avec quand même des décès enfin
je veux dire ne croyons pas
qu'aujourd'hui on est complètement à
l'abri de tel donc il faut qu'on essaie
je défends aucun voyez je essaie de
défendre aucun lobby j'ai moi j'ai j'ai
on a on a pris les décisions en
conscience vis-à-vis de ce qu'avait dit
LAN et la question de la dose maximale
et de la question quand même d'avoir des
produits dont on peut justifier qui soit
fait par des procès qui puissent le
faire et d's je dis au passage c'est les
grandes firmes de production de charcuti
sont pas très gêné par l'interdiction de
nétrite s'affire en Massin c'est donc
c'est pas une question principalement de
lobby sur la question je reprends du
début monsieur sur la question de la
mise en œuvre de la PAC euh donc on a un
élément important qui est celui de la
transmission au région d'un certain
nombre de prérogatives en termees de de
politique agricole commune bon c'est un
choix qui a été fait à l'époque alors
c'est assez intéressant parce que on a
repris les surfaciques les mesures ja
sont été reprises par les régions euh
comme vous le savez je suis plutôt
décentralisateur et étant un pur produit
de la démocratie locale et en même temps
partout où je me promène à chaque fois
sur les sujets de notation jeun
d'riculteur on me demande
quoi la
recentralisation tel agriculteur du
nouvel aquitain veut être adopté par la
région auverne renalp considérant que le
dispositif est plus attractif tel autre
considère qu'il y a trop de conditions
par rapport à d'autres région bon c'est
la c'est la différenciation et la
décentralisation mais c'est vrai que ça
pose une question est-ce qu'on a une
politique agricole commune nationale
quand on a c'est donc on essaie de
travailler avec les régions mais après
elles ont leurs prérogatives elles
peuvent se mettre de la conditionnalité
mais il y a quelque chose qui est assez
fascinant de voir que maintenant on
viendrait presque nous reprocher alors
que parfois on nous reproche de faire
l'inverse d'avoir fait trop de
décentralisation donc c'est assez
intéressant à regarder deuxième élément
il y a un sujet sur le transfert sur la
la
question comment
diraisje sur la
question du transfert des effectifs et
des des dossier
dja j'avais été interrogé dès que je
suis arrivé par les régions pour
regarder si les effectifs dont on avait
BES besoin dont ils avaient besoin
étaaiit bien conforme au effectifs qui
avaient été transfér on a plutôt fait un
effort et je crois que les l' RF vous
dirait qu'on a plutôt fait un effort de
d'effectif qui permet de mettre en
adéquation après toujours des débats
interminables mais il y avait deux
choses c'est c'était des fonctionnaires
des DDT à qui ont proposé l'option
d'aller travailler en région tous ne
l'ont pas fait selon les modalités qui
étaient offertes par les régions et je
va pas citer non parce que ça n'a aucune
importance je suis pas mon genre en
plus donc ça s'est plus ou moins bien
passé donc parfois ils ont été obligé de
recruter exnilo des gens qui
instruisaient des dossiers qui n'avaient
pas l'expérience puis parfois ils ont
récupéré tous les effectifs et
globalement ça s'est pas mal passé ce
qui explique des différences parfois de
retard ça c'est une une première
explication et donc on a des régions qui
sont un peu en tension ce qui a justifié
d'une mesure que j'ai prise récemment
sur la Bourgogne franchecé parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup trop de tension je
considère entre la Région et le et les
agriculteurs en particulier les jeunes
et que moi je n'ai nulle intention de de
de regarder comme ça alors que je n'ai
plus aucune prérogative dans le registre
donc on a pris l'engagement de reprendre
d'abord 200 dossiers puis on reprend 250
dossiers en instruction pour faire en
sorte qu'on écoule le stock pardon du
terme le stock étant des dossiers qui
sont des demandes de subvention et le
stock étant des dossiers qui n'ont pas
encore obtenu le paiement et donc ça on
est en train d'y travailler parce que je
pense qu'effectivement donc on l'a fait
en bonne intelligence je crois avec la
présidente de région après une
explication qui a été un peu solide on
va dire ça comme ça mais je ne voulais
pas qu'on dis c'est la faute de l'État
qui nous que cela parce que dans
beaucoup de régions ça se passe à peu
près correctement il y en a
quelques-unes où ça se passe mal je je
pas de jugement hein mais je pense que
c'est important quand même de faire en
sorte qu'on on déploie parce que ça ça
nuit évidemment donc il faut les
dossiers qui sont en cours et pour la
suite essayer d'accompagner donc on a
mis des moyens ce qui n'était pas
obligatoire on a mis des moyens au
niveau national auprès des régions on a
dégagé des moyens des DDT pour permettre
l'instruction des dossiers euh troisème
sujet qui est évoqué l'adhésion merci
monsieur le sénateur d'abord de du merci
du merci sur la question des mesures
agrienvironnementales je pense qu'on a
une bonne PIST alors maintenant on me
dit c'est pas assez oui je pense que ça
couvre les besoins en particulier breton
parce que je m'intéresse à la Bretagne
mais pas que mais vous avez raison et
c'est bien que vous me m'obligé à aller
plus loin dans ce que je voulais dire
non c'est pas la même chose si vous êtes
intégré ou pas non non mais vous avez RA
non non mais mais j'ai dit que ne
croyons pas que non non dans l'Union il
y a pas d'effet quand même quand même
parce que c'est une puissance agricole à
N frontière bon et d'ors et déjà sur un
certain nombre de marchés elle elle est
venue depuis des années elle est venue
depuis des années et ça me ramènera à la
question sur les frontières kinourkii si
je peux dire donc la principale le
principal élément c'est d'un point de
vue tactique comme vous avez l'avez dit
c'est pas la pâack de 2027 c'est la
pâack au moins celle
d'après non mais donc on a une
temporalité lointaine je pense qu'on
aura besoin de réfléchir à ce que est ce
qui est la PAC de toute façon qu'est-ce
qu'on en veut pe parce qu'il y a des
choses qui ont changé le dérèglement
climatique des revenus qui sont très
arrthmiques du fait de la géopolitique
de l'économie qui et du climat qui ont
beaucoup changé qui change tout le temps
donc il faut se poser ces questions là
dans le temps qui nous amène à 2027 et
2032 deè élément personne n'imagine que
on on on soit juste à dire bah c'est un
pays qui rentre il y a tant d'hectares
et tant d'exploitation une exploitation
qui a 400000 hectares vous m'entendez
bien est-ce qu'elle doit bénéficier des
mêmes soutiens qu'une exploitation qui a
100 poser la question c'est un peu y
répondre poser poser la question c'est
un peu y répondre donc c'est aussi une
voie qu'on peut mais je d'ailleurs les
Ukrainiens la
vérité contrairement à d'autres
adhésions qui a pu avoir il en fait pas
grief il cherchent pas après les crédits
de la PAC hein c'est pas leur sujet ils
sont très compétitifs sans les crédits
de la PAC ils ont un système qui
s'équilibre ils ont des marchés et ils
sont compétitifs sur les marchés
oui mais attention à ce que de
l'intérieur ou de l'extérieur c'est pour
ça que je dis qu'il faut quand même pas
délier le sujet c'est voyez bien que si
nous on se lit les mains et qu'on arrive
pas à produire et qu'on est c'est plus
40 millions de tonnes qui nous manque de
céréal mais 60 ou 70 millions on va
avoir un problème qui est un peu lourd
vous voyez ce que je veux dire et que
c'est eux qui viendront couvrir le
besoin donc on a besoin quand même de
rentrer en dialogue donc ça n'est pas la
même chose vous avez raison de me le
faire
dire mais quand même ils sont là et ils
sont là comme une puissance agricole et
donc je pense que dans le processus
d'adhésion qui soit long comme il va
l'être ou que Bou est pas il me semble
qu'il faut quand même se mettre dans la
situation où nous avons besoin d'avoir
avec nous l'Ukraine comme
partenaire et non pas comme concurrent
sur nos marchés parce qu'on a besoin
avec eux de construire une stratégie
Europe continant pas Europe Union
européenne sur la question agricole et
donc il faut s'en faire ses alliés c'est
là que je dis qu'il y a des sujets qu'il
faut quand même travailler quoi qui se
passe ça si je peux me permettre sur la
question des sur la question des prix on
a vécu cet
épisode du des céréal ukrainienne qui
était destinée à l'Afrique et qui
transitait par les pays de l'Union
européenne à tel point que on a dû
fermer des quelques frontières enfin les
les États-membres ont fermé les
frontières dans la mesure où les prix
avaient été complètement cassé donc en
fait on a un peu vécu ce que pouvait
être l'apport des céréales ukrainiennes
sur le marché il y a quand même moi
j'avais rencontré à l'époque les les les
Polonais beaucoup d'exploitations
agricooles avaient été mise en faillite
brutalement parce que le prix du blé
avait été complètement abaissé de de
Moyer moitié voire voire trois fois
moins et et donc voilà la question
d'Alain Cadec elle revient à ça c'est
dire un certain moment comment on
intègre ce géant au risque de voir des
prix qui qui vont qui vont baisser et
comme vous le disiez par rapport aux
exploitations une exploitation de
plusieurs milliers d'hectares par
rapport à une exploitation de sang elle
a plus de capacité à pouvoir baisser ses
prix que celle de sang non mais c'est
tout l' je rebondis pas plus mais c'est
tout l'enjeu de notre faire évidemment
c'est tout l'enjeu de notre affaire
mais comment dire c'est le sujet c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec ce géant qui
est en train de naître à nos frontièr
mais pas seulement le sujet de
l'intégration ou pas l'intégration parce
que le sujet c'est quand même
celui-là nous sommes une puissance séalè
parce que nous sommes une puissance
exportatrice
séaliire bon nous France et parfois en
qualité d'ailleurs ça m'amènera à
répondre à la question sur sur les
frontières mais donc il me semble que
c'est un élément important de de se le
dire comment avec de parce que avec les
Ukrainiens on a une puissance agricole
européenne sans les Ukrainiens c'est
différent et donc qu'est-ce qu'on essaie
de construire avec eux c'est ça le
chemin qu'on a à faire j'en finis sur la
question bah NBT NGT
euh pardon si il y a quand même enfin je
répète j'essaie de pas être trop trop
fluctuant dans dans ce que disent les
avis
l'fsa les scientifiques disent
globalement que les risques sur les C
ces nouvelles techniques génomiqu ne son
son sont marginaux voir inexistants bon
alors on est dans un monde de
controverse il y a aussi des gens qui
nous expliquaient que qu'il fallait
prendre de la javelle contre contre le
le le covid ou qui nous ont déconseillé
de nous vacciner donc on est dans un
monde qui est comme ça qui est un monde
où il y a plus de de de fi scientifique
tout à fait avéré et donc il y a
toujours quelqu'un qui vient vous
expliquer qu'il a une étude
complémentaire qui vient dire exactement
l'inverse de ce que dit la majorité des
scientifiques alors moi j'ai tendance à
me retourner vers la majorité des
scientifiques c'est ça que je veux dire
et et je disais tout à l'heure aussi je
répète se priver de ça c'est à terme se
livrer à d'autres c'est aussi simple que
ça c'est aussi simple que ça c'est aussi
simple que ça parce que tout le monde
est en train de les utiliser et c'est un
levier puissant de la transformation du
modèle agricole parce que si on veut pas
de produit phyos si on veut pas de NBT
NGT si on veut pas non plus travailler
la question de l'eau je ne sais pas
comment on va produire je le dis très
simplement et j'ajoute et je réponds à
la question que vous avez par ailleurs
et j'en finis sur euh sur l'export russe
qu'est-ce que sont en train de faire les
Russes d'abord parce que nous sommes en
en en situation plus critique puisque
nous sommes obligés d'importer au niveau
européen c'est en céréales donc on a
moins de disponibilité les seuls pays
qui en ont un peu c'est la France bon
deuxème élément les Russes sont en train
de saturer le marché avec des prix très
bas avec une qualité qui est médiocre
compris en alimentation humaine ce qui
est un élément comparatif supérieur pour
nous parce qu'on peut aller encore sur
ces marchés parce que on sait ce qu'on
achète quand on achète des céréales
françaises mais évidemment cette
questionl elle est importante parce que
aujourd'hui les Russes sont en train
d'organiser aux frontières et sur le
continent EUR africain évidemment une
dépendance de ces pays-là et pour
répondre à ça il y a pas d'autrre
solution que nous soyons aussi des des
acteurs du jeu et donc on ça rejoint ce
que je disais tout à l'heure que nous
soyons en capacité de fournir et de
produire parce que si nous ne sommes pas
en capacité de fournir et produire on va
regarder monsieur Poutine placer ses
dominosx ou ses pions avant que ça ne
soit un domino d'ailleurs sur la
question et donc je pense que c'est
extrêmement
comment dirais-je ça doit être un un
point de grande vigilance et c'est là
que l'Europe a rendez-vous un peu avec
sa stratégie de
souveraineté j'avais un débat l'autre
jour avec le commissaire européen sur il
disait bah le marché des céréales en
gros on produit en gros cette année
autant que les autres années sauf qu'il
y a pas dans toutes les mêmes zones de
la même façon et si je je tire le
raisonnement oui il y a il y a de
l'énergie gaz et pétrolière par
suffisamment pour tout le monde sauf qui
les
détient et c'est c'est la c'est
l'aveuglement qu'on a eu sur la question
du gaz en disant mais il y en a il est
chez les Russes oui très bien enfin il
était chez des gens qui sont devenus nos
adversaires et donc cette question de je
le répète ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
de qui nourrit les Français et les
Européens et qui nourrit les les les les
frontières les plus proches de nous sur
ce sujet-là il me semble que c'est une
question assez assez centrale et donc à
ce moment-là il va falloir qu'on a quand
même des outils pour le faire et donc
autant je dis qu'il faut qu'on ait une
trajectoire de réduction des produits
photosanitaires autant je pense quand
même qu'il faut se doter des outils les
NBT ici les NGT NBT NGT là les pratiques
agricoles aussi parce que sinon on va se
retrouver assez rapidement dans une
situation d'ASS on l'est déjà en partie
hein on l' déjà en partie parce que
c'est pas des marchés où nous venons
imposer au monde les
règles c'est c'est la la nécessité de
nourrir qui impose ces règles on a eu un
un débat au début de l'année sur la
question de l'utilisation de la fausse
fine pour les les céréales bon j'ai
beaucoup pvré pour qu'on libè les choses
parce que pourquoi parce qu'on se
retrouveit dans la situation où nous ne
pourrions plus d'une fait des décision
domestique si je peux dire exporter des
céréales vers des pays qui demande de la
faus fine qui est un produit insecticide
qui permet de se garantir de
l'importation sur les territoires de
d'insectes bon ce n'était pas nous qui
le voulions c'est c'est une demande si
c'est pas nous qui le
faisons on ouvre les paquebos les
tankerss à Monsieur monsieur Poutine
parce que c'est des partenaires
commerciaux nous n'avons pas à leur
dictter ce qu'il ils veulent on veut pas
de beau de Vau hormones très bien et et
tant mieux mais s'ils veulent des
produits qui sont telle ou telle nature
c'est comme ça de même que on parle
souvent de bien-être animal et gens
finini pardon monsieur le Président
euh le transport d'animaux vivants la
question c'est pas d'imposer à l'Algérie
au Maroc et à la Tunisie le transport
d'animaux nonvvants parce que ils
veulent transporter des animaux
vivants donc soit c'est nous soit c'est
d'autre mais c'est un choix et on peut
faire toutes les réglementations qu'on
veut
si c'est pas nous ça sera d'autrre alors
après on peut essayer d'améliorer nous
les conditions de faire en sorte que ça
se passe dans de meilleures conditions
j'ai aucun problème avec ça enfin quand
même essayons de le faire avec toujours
en tête le fait qu'aujourd'hui je pense
que la puissance agricole européenne
puisque nous sommes dans un cadre
européen elle est quand même en risque
pour les raisons que j'évoqué tout à
l'heure très bien merci c'était c'était
très clair
et peut-être on aura l'occasion de se
voir il va y avoir encore de l'actualité
agricole euh au niveau européen et je
pense que le le le mandat qui s'annonce
et l'ouverture du mandat qui s'annonce
avec cet enjeu fort hein de la
souveraineté euh sera sera un élément
qui nous amènera euh à à à nous revoir
merci monsieur le ministre de vous être
livré à ce ce jeu de
questions-réponse je demande au au
commissaire de rester j'ai j'ai juste
deux trois euh deux trois éléments à
faire valider trs prê espace on est prêt
voilà